le best-of des vidéos flippante
s'allonge te j'te fuck un truc au [ __ ]
[ __ ] reste bas c'est pour ça j'ai cru
que ça lui faisait peur en fait c'est
sega slender qu'ils agressent des
bonbons dire attendez un peu wok et je
peux passer une photo je déteste il nous
a prévenus position foetale
il peut m'arriver position foetale son
chariot de quoi le croyez quoi de quoi
mais tout ça et de l'est je cherche la
bouteille de lait jeannot je suis allé
la chercher
c'est par où oui oui oui c'est en fait à
un bien commun ils nombre une silhouette
noire
on a salué aucun est clean les yeux ya
une vitre ou non est un mix entre comme
stender il fait pas ça non non non non
ouakame j'emmerde je sens le truc parce
que ça fait longtemps
je sors le trio folk
ah ah
ah ah ah mr coton tige
toi mon [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] aulas y a un truc là
c'est parce dender non c'est un bug ça
fait dur en panne à l'état joue peu à
l'étagé c'est parti laitages d'ailleurs
je suis passé là je me souviens y avait
pas la page ben oui encore
cette cerise il ya le jaune violet le
rouge de perles bleues carré en juillet
bah enfin qui sait que cette forme au
croyable tu es nul moi je joue déjà en
position foetale position foetale
position foetale puis sur pénaltouche
pas vous êtes en position foetale
on va essayer de longer les murs non non
ça va marcher belle merde
ces idées de merde en fait le mec a créé
juste un gros mytho il a mis deux photos
et l'a fait trop mais toi monstre
faire la guerre à mettre à la casse elle
habite mca-bénin
aaaaaah coucou coucou record caucourt
mon attention
tel était le cas
q